TOP ADVISOR TO KIM JONG UN.
NEGOTIATIONS TO REVIVE THE
CANCELED SUMMIT ON JUNE 12
CONTINUE.
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON HAS THE
STATEMENT FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> THE AMERICAN SECRETARY OF
STATE AND THE NORTH KOREAN VICE
CHAIRMAN ART IN NEW YORK.
THE HIGHEST LEVEL NORTH KOREAN
VISIT TO THE UNITED STATES IN 18
YEARS.
>> OF THE CONVERSATION WILL BE
FOCUSED ON DENUCLEARIZATION OF
THE PENINSULA.
THAT'S WHAT THESE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS TAKING PLACE NOW
WILL BE CENTERED ON, AS WELL AS
THE SUMMIT THAT WOULD TAKE PLACE
IN SINGAPORE.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION SAYS
SECRETARY POMPEO WILL JOIN VICE
CHAIRMAN KIM JONG-CHUL FOR
DINNER TONIGHT.
TOMORROW, AND A DAY OF MEETINGS
TO SET UP A SUMMIT.
AT THE SECRETARY AND KIM
JONG-CHUL HAVE MET TWICE BEFORE,
WHEN POMPEO TRAVELED TO
PYONGYANG AS CIA DIRECTOR AND
LATER AS SECRETARY OF STATE.
>> IF THEY'VE HAD OBVIOUSLY VERY
DEEP CONVERSATIONS WHERE THEY
TALKED ABOUT LOTS OF DETAIL
ABOUT WHAT THE UNITED STATES
EXPECTATIONS ARE.
KIM JONG-CHUL IS IMMERSED IN
RECENT DIPLOMACY.
HE SPENT SEVERAL YEARS LEADING
NORTH KOREA'S INTELLIGENT
SERVICE AND IS STILL UNDER U.S.
SANCTIONS.
HE IS SUSPECTED TO HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN NORTH KOREA'S
NUCLEAR PROGRAM, THE SINKING OF
A SOUTH KOREAN SHIP IN 2010, AND
EVEN THE HACK OF SONY IN 2014.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAID
SECRETARY POMPEO SPOKE FOR THE
WEEKEND WITH FOREIGN MINISTERS
FROM SOUTH KOREA AND SINGAPORE
AND HE SCHEDULED TO MEET NEXT
WEEK WITH THE JAPANESE
PRIME MINISTER IN WASHINGTON.
NORTH KOREA IS ALSO PLANNING
WITH ITS ALLIES AHEAD OF THE
JUNE 12TH SUMMIT.
THE MINISTER LOVE ROB IS
EXPECTED TO TRAVEL TO
NORTH KOREA THIS WEEK.
AS THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA SHOWINGR
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA SHOWINGN
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA SHOWINGW
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA SHOWINGD
STRAIN.
JAMES MATTIS PROMISES THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO SAIL THROUGH
DISPUTED INTERNATIONAL WATERS
THAT CHINA CONSIDERS ITS
TERRITORY.
>> THERE IS A VERY STEADY
DRUMBEAT OF NAVIGATION
OPERATIONS, BUT YOU WILL NOTICE
THERE IS ONLY ONE COUNTRY THAT
SEEMS TO TAKE ACTIVE STEPS TO
REBUFF THEM OR STAKE THEIR
RESENTMENT OF THEM.
>> OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
ALSO SAYS IT'S MOVING FORWARD
WITH TARIFFS ON CHINESE IMPORTS
AND RESTRICTIONS ON CHINESE